the american political landscape has
changed drastically over you could say
in the past decade going from president
obama to president trump and now to
president biden and joining me now to
share some of his takes on some of the
latest events that have happened in
american politics as well as to discuss
his show the david pakman show is david
pakman david thanks so much for making
the time and and for joining me here
today perhaps we can start it with um
something that happened where i'm
speaking to you from today in canada a
u.s senator from west virginia joe
manchin
came to canada and he um
met with
alberta premier jason kenney and um in
terms of you know where jason kenny sits
on the political spectrum he's on um the
more conservative side um joe manchin i
guess i don't even really know where you
would characterize him on the political
spectrum but um i guess is there very
much um is there very many people within
the democratic party um that you know
would fit the spectrum of joe manchin
and what does it say that you know joe
manchin is you know going
to other countries in this case canada
specifically to the province of alberta
which alberta for people that don't know
is obviously what's known as the oil and
gas province um so i guess you speak a
little bit about what you think that
means
yeah i mean i think you there's been
this strange mass kind of in the middle
in the united states politically
where you've got the more centrist or
even right-leaning democrats
and the more centrist or left-leaning
republicans who are not that different
from each other so for example the
republican senator mitt romney if you
look at policy
he's not dramatically different than
somebody like joe manchin at the end of
the day although i find romney to be a
man of more integrity than mansion
despite being a left-leaning independent
myself
um and so i think that
trumpism has caused not a realignment
but kind of a reconsideration of what
the parties mean and what are the sides
you know i've said for a long time wyatt
that i don't really find many trump
supporters to really be
conservative
uh
individuals in in the style of someone
like a mitt romney or even george bush i
consider them neo-reactionaries who
entered the political world because of
trump and to support trump and i don't
know where they're going to land at the
end of the day i don't know where
someone like joe manchin's going to land
at the end of the day
and obviously mitt romney for example as
you mentioned you brought up his name so
perhaps i'll go there he's a you know
he's a republican from a very
conservative state as opposed to someone
like joe manchin is a democrat from west
virginia which has been known as you
know a conservative state at least for
the past couple of election cycles so i
mean in a way you could you know say
that you know joe manchin may you know
have to be carefully looking at you know
um the policy that he kind of develops i
guess in order to
i guess represent the interests of you
know the people of west virginia how old
how big of a role i guess do you see um
you know the constituency area that you
represent playing in i guess in this
case as i mentioned joe manchin and the
views that he now holds
there's no set rule so if you are um a
left-leaning democrat in a very blue
state
you can more or less do whatever you
want because it's very unlikely that the
voters in that state are even going to
primary you never mind a vote for a
republican now you could say that that's
bad that it's too safe it's too comfy
for some of these members of the house
or senate that
they there's very little accountability
because it's sort of like a rubber stamp
or you could say that it gives them the
freedom to kind of be who they are you
know sometimes susan collins a senator
from maine or republican has mentioned
where there's the idea that because the
main the this is the story that's told
by it that the main republicans are more
open-minded and thoughtful than in some
other places so she can be a more
moderate republican that's like one
story that's told the other story is
susan collins says a lot of things about
being disappointed with the republican
party but at the end of the day she
basically just votes with the republican
party so what does that independence
really grant her but to go to your
question about joe manchin you know a
lot of times democrats say
we've got a primary joe manchin we've
just got to get him out of there we've
got to primary him with a more
progressive democrat
i think if you do that the seat goes to
a republican because as you point out
the voters in west virginia aren't
looking for bernie sanders and so for me
joe manchin is a problem but the
solution isn't necessarily primary a
democratic senator in west virginia it's
flipping seats in more moderate states
so then i guess two questions as it
would you know relate to that i mean if
joe manchin for example is voting more
on the uh you know republican side of
things obviously he's was one of the
main issues as it related to the build
back better plan i guess um but then
also i mean um i guess how much of a gap
is there now between people like that
you know the bernie sanders and the
alexandria ocasio-cortez of the
democratic party versus you know types
of people like joe manchin it's a
significant gap now you could say
there's also a gap that's built on the
republican party that the difference
between marjorie taylor green and mitt
romney is like the grand canyon right
you could make that case but i don't
know which would be bigger at this point
but there's a pretty serious gap in
terms of i mean what you're getting to
when you talk about bernie and aoc
versus mansion
it's really a difference over the
fundamental roles of government and
business and these are not small issues
these are not like well
i want the top tax rate to be 36 and you
want it to be 37 right that would be a
more minor issue but these are pretty
fundamental issues and the question that
we're going to answer through elections
is
is it so much that it starts to rip the
democratic party apart i don't know the
answer yet
and i guess my next question would be in
terms of as we've mentioned already
there's people who sit on you know
people like bernie sanders alexandria
ocasio-cortez's of the world and then
there's people who are you know
far-right leading uh politicians to what
extent is american politics defined by
you know just moderates or i guess
center right leaning or center left
leaning people or do you think you know
those types of people are hard to come
by now based off of you know how
politics i guess now is kind of defined
as left and right so this this was a
really interesting question during the
democratic primary where if you looked
superficially at twitter and read it
you would have gotten the impression
that bernie was just going to run away
with this democratic nomination it's
just the the support is overwhelming
and then as we got into the primaries
you started to see that a lot of people
who just are busy working and they don't
have time to be on reddit and twitter
for lack of a better term um
actually were significantly more
centrist and it ended up not being a
small i mean joe biden won significantly
in the democratic primary and you can go
back and say well when so many people
get out and say support biden of course
he's going to build a lead but even
before that happened joe biden was doing
much better than you would have thought
if you looked at reddit so for me i
don't say this because it gives me
pleasure i mean i'm to the left of joe
biden for sure but i think if you ignore
reality
you're not going to do well in terms of
elections and and i think your question
is an astute one which is there is still
a much more moderate presence in
american politics than social media
might suggest which is quite extreme and
uh
opposite black and white by comparison
specifically i guess if you look at
various you know voting demographics
various age demographics obviously
there's different issues that various
age demographics care about but
specifically you know if you look at um
i guess you know young americans or uh
you know middle-aged americans obviously
you know they're gonna have issues as it
relates to you know i guess
affordability um housing
issues around surrounding that social
issues as well um which specifically on
social issues many people would
obviously argue that the democrats take
you know better stances on those because
you know specifically with i guess you
could say lgbtq rights and and various
things such as that um do you think
there's a way that the republicans could
i guess you know take some of the
support away from the democrats with you
know the policy that they currently have
because right now it seems as if you
know a lot of as i mentioned the social
issue policy i guess specifically seems
to be you know appealing to young people
of the democrats i have said before on
my show
that if republicans
rallied around justin as an example
cannabis legalization and student loan
forgiveness i know it doesn't line up
with a lot of what they push but just
imagine for a second that republicans
said hey you know what we're going to do
what we've been doing but we want to
decriminalize or legalize cannabis and
we want to do some student loan
forgiveness i think democrats get
absolutely destroyed i think there is
such a hankering for that and we could
talk about other issues too
that if republicans did it democrats are
so poorly organized um
that that i think it would be crushing
to democrats if republicans thought to
do that i don't think they will but
and as it relates to the 2022 midterms
obviously you know a lot of the same
issues that i mentioned in my last
question will be you know relevant and
present probably in in the 2022 midterm
elections what issues are you keeping
your eye on as it relates to the 2022
midterms and you know what do you think
democrats or republicans uh the
democratic or republican party will have
to do to
earn the support of americans on those
various policy issues
well i go back to what the political
strategist james carville said back when
he was working for bill clinton
um and it's the economy stupid and it's
sort of a crass way of saying i mean i
still think at this point even though
i've spent hours on my show explaining
how gas prices and inflation these are
global cyclical systemic issues it's not
joe biden's fault if voters believe that
it is they're going to punish democrats
for it and even if they don't literally
believe it's biden's fault if they just
say
things don't seem great
they typically still punish whoever's in
power so i think it's going to be
mo last week i don't know if you saw
this this study wyatt but there was a
study done which asked people
do you believe that jobs have been
created or lost under joe biden
and the the real answer is jobs have
been created
about a third of the country believes
jobs have been lost under joe biden so
even though the jobs numbers are good if
people think that they're bad
they will punish you for that so i think
it'll be mostly an economic referendum i
do think if we have a
problematic coveted resurgence it will
also probably hurt democrats
and the perception of joe biden's job
with the invasion of russia
by russia of ukraine
will probably be a factor although right
now americans mostly think he's doing a
pretty good job on that
and then just super quickly i i mean i
guess in terms of what you said last
time i guess that or in your last answer
obviously relates to misinformation i
mean how do you um how how should
americans and how should you know people
um you know counter misinformation
specifically as it relates to political
issues because obviously you know it
we've seen it relevant a lot during
covet but also on various other issues
that misinformation has become a very
big issue
there's no easy answer to this you know
the solution comes when everybody's your
age wyatt that's the reality you know if
we have to create i recently interviewed
dr steven novella about this who's great
on this issue critical thinking media
literacy
it's very hard
to put people in the framework of
evaluating their own thoughts
if they don't
if they're not taught to do it much
earlier on and so unfortunately i don't
want to say that the current electorate
is a lost cause it's not it's not we
still can do work there but we really
need to need to be working on these
issues when people are way younger so
they never fall for this stuff in the
first place
okay that is david pakman host of the
david packard show david thanks so much
for your time today and for providing
some of your insight wyatt this has been
great i'm going to direct people to your
channel you're doing a really great job